alright this is a completely crazy story
so burials in Japan have become so
expensive on average twenty seven
thousand dollars which is like 2.2
million yen or so they become so
expensive that people are launching
their cremated relatives into space
which that part actually sounds kind of
cool to me you can send your relatives
ashes into space Elysium space
incorporated which I wonder if that came
out before the movie or not I think it
did they will send the cremated remains
of your mom or dad to circle the earth
for several months for only 1999 sad eel
and then you can of course track where
your relative is because there's an app
for that that's right let's look at some
of the facts about the service about one
gram of a person's remains are placed
into an individual space grade aluminum
capsule missions will carry between 100
and 400 individual capsules and cost of
renting a burial plot as I said and a
tombstone in Tokyo is about 2727 400 oz
so twenty seven thousand four hundred
dollars so we can all end up in space I
guess that's where we'll start on this
Rick are you going to space when you
leave this mortal coil that's one of
those things that look so great on paper
yeah and they're kind of I hope they've
factored in the ozone depletion because
if that's a space grade aluminum
cylinder people might start making it in
and the irony is you know you're at the
funeral for your loved one and you get
hit by the message flaming meteorite
slams in from you know upper atmosphere
yeah gives new meaning to a sign that's
right yeah yeah I love that renting the
space to renting it you know it's
uptight that they got to evict them you
know ya gotta kick him out when they
didn't make rent I think that it might
be safer than living in Japan at this
point there's some major start living
the alive people up out of there too
yeah you know I mean what do you think
if they if it's a cheaper alternative
actually the idea of having some part of
you go into space when this thing's over
actually kind of appeals to me yeah what
do you think I mean for me it's one of
those things it's like frightening and
cool when I think about it just
emotionally I'm like oh my god that's a
scary I don't even want to know about
this and like
that's really cool while my ashes shot
into space I mean where else do I
wouldn't be you know right it's like
we're such nomads we're really wanna be
there just be shot into space okay yeah
seriously I mean things if you if it
costs thirty thousand dollars to bury
you and this is safe to do then it seems
like it's a decent alternative I mean it
sounds weird it sounds freaking people
probably gonna complain that something
about is morally wrong or whatever but I
want to know what the scientists say I
want to know what people that actually
study space at NASA and everyone says
and if they're cool with it besides the
fact that we're gonna have like space
garbage people floating around right so
that's so the size right so the sci-fi
part of my brain immediately what I
thought was okay we're going to send all
this well gravity of course but we're
going to send all these ashes of dead
people up there and then aliens are
going to be flying by and they're going
to see the ashes and they're gonna think
it's a threat like look what we did to
the last guy we're sending you their
ration they send themselves and
concentrate for ya do it out ready thats
enough thats part two where you put some
water on it and then the whole other
story injured like mafia son like
clothes they're aliens like wooden space
the dead fish is just a mess on your
Porsche a dead horse in your bed ashes
and its Prometheus it is yeah it's all
okay sides right know where it goes what
happens it just stays in oroville so
they orbited a couple times around for a
couple months and then it just don't
know cuz it's in this it's in those
capsule they're gonna send a whole bunch
of them up together and then I think oh
no no I I know you track it you track it
and then like a meteorite the remains
disintegrates upon entering the Earth's
at ok that's cool I'm dad yeah I've ever
been to Tokyo no the apartments are like
where this small people are like stacked
almost on top of each other it's
incredibly expensive it's incredibly
busy and loud and pollution is going up
and it's you know it's it's a nice
cities my favorite City I've ever been
to but you can tell there's absolutely
no space I can't even imagine how space
/ I mean to me I'm like I have no idea
where they would put these people and if
they're gonna just disintegrate after
that that's kind of poetic and cool I'm
into this as long as they disintegrate
because every time you launch a rocket
you're putting another little hole in
the ozone you keep launching rockets at
the speed they need to to get rid of all
the day be mass launching them in others
be cost effective can imagine every time
someone
dad a new rocket my brown one costumers
gonna be more of a limo rape in a cab if
it's one professor it's not going to be
nineteen hundred and ninety dollars I
can't the one customer I'm sorry you
gotta sweep your card again yeah yeah
it's got a mess hey guys the Rubin
report is brought to you by Cooper calm
they've got seventy-five percent off dog
and cat choose toys accessories home
goods and more use code RR for twenty
percent off your next purchase the link
is right down there